hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
duties of reparation often arise when
you break
this is something really unique to
Ross's ethics then he makes reparation
fixing things so central to his moral
theory I think that's something really
quite interesting there's a recognition
that there are going to be a lot of
cases where we do something wrong where
we failed in one of our duties or it's
another person including the duty not to
harm them right where we make things
worse for them where we let them down
yeah and he says that in these sorts of
cases we incur in obligation upon
ourselves oftentimes we'll say things
like well it couldn't be helped I'm not
really responsible
Ross would say you know if you hurt
somebody even if like you couldn't help
it you know you were you were sick at
the time and didn't realize that you
were gonna bump into them you're still
in some sense responsible you still want
to try to make up for it he says duties
resting on a previous wrongful actor are
duties of reparation and he he talks
about these in a bunch of different
places notice what else he says he says
this with reparation and he also says it
with gratitude he's not so interested in
the feeling it's action
that matters you know and when we fail
when we do wrong when we let people down
we we should feel and we often do feel
that but that's not what the duty of
recreation is the duty of recreation is
to they actually do something to try to
acknowledge and if possible set things
right now this is really interesting in
part because I think a lot of people
don't realize that ethics is not just
about learning the code that's going to
you know set everything on the right
track it's about figuring out how to
quit screwing up your life and the lives
of other people around you because now a
third by the time that you actually
start to study ethics and think about
these sort of things you've got some
ways in which you screw up routinely and
you want to be able to think about what
should I do
I don't want it to stop doing those
things I actually have a duty to in some
way make up for so let's just start with
apologies you know what what does a good
apology consistent for you what do you
want to see part of the person yeah yeah
that that's important they recognize
that there's something wrong so some one
of those BS apologies like I'm sorry
that you feel that way we thought that's
a terrible thing to say it's alright you
guys say you wronged me I'm sorry you
feel that way
that's not acknowledging anything that's
like adding a new yeah being willing to
say I did something that I shouldn't
yeah that's that's part
yeah um being reassured that they're not
going to do it again yeah making some
sort of resolve and not just like you
know some some you know BS words I'll
never do it again
I'm so sorry just give me another chance
I mean sometimes people mean that but
sometimes that's like the way people
keep justifying if somebody keeps up
doing the wrong thing you might you know
like for example somebody who bursts out
a terrible rage against you in order to
keep from doing it again maybe they need
to go to anger management
you know maybe they need to be in a a
group counseling situation that would
actually show that would be an action
you don't have to like hint around
anything you're sorry yep that's good
they think there's a certain spontaneity
to it okay that makes sense
I mean mr. branch would say that if you
had to remind them or bring it to their
attention but they did actually
apologize they are fulfilling their duty
but just not as well anything else that
goes into a a good apology for you now
what about making things right
apologizing is one thing does
apologizing always fix things it's kind
of good to do but doesn't actually fix
up what else that people need to do
let's think about some ordinary
situations I screw up your car what
should I do
fix your car right that that's fairly
easy to do
I reveal some secret that you told me
and told it in confidence and it's
damaging for others from Noah and I
reveal it
how many make up for that that's a
little tougher isn't it maybe I didn't
do what I can to restore your reputation
yeah but suppose all that just makes
everybody more misery at least takes
attention away from person think what if
I what if I cheated my marriage how do I
make up for that I mean how do people
try to become that candy renewal the
vows flowers
not really do is it if if you can be
made if everything can be made okay by
bouquet flowers for breaking you know
once marriage vows thing we're really
taking those vows that serious in the
first place what might actually make up
saying to the other person one you get
to cheat too
I don't know that's probably not the
solution notice a lot of times with
duties of reparation it's hard to figure
out exactly what would satisfy the
requirement to to make things up and we
can fail in respect to any avail in not
apologizing not recognize
we do things wrong there's the reflexive
aspect to this some people just don't
like to apologize or every left that
they're wrong that's wrong any person if
you know in a second way if you've
already won
what are you do think of this this is
something we haven't talked about until
this point in the semester do you feel
like you do they actually have duties to
make things right with you do things
wrong well that's pretty basic what do
you think about people who don't think
they have any duties to make things
right when they don't things right do
you know any people yeah that might be
that might be the problem or they're so
self-centered that they can't see any
reason why they should